[Music]
I've thought a long time about what
motivates behavior like that manifested
at Columbine and at Sandy Hook and then
of course most recently at parkland and
because of the parkland event I thought
that I would read a chapter from my book
to everyone it's chapter six rule six
set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world and it's an
extended meditation on the kind of
motivations that drive the people who
wish to slaughter innocents as a form of
revenge against God so I'm going to read
it to you and you can let me know what
you think rule six set your house in
perfect order before you criticize the
world a religious problem it does not
seem reasonable to describe the young
man who shot twenty children and six
staff members at Sandy Hook Elementary
School in Newton Connecticut in 2012 as
a religious person this is equally true
for the Colorado theater gunman and the
Columbine high school shooters but these
murderous individuals had a problem with
reality that existed at a religious
depth as one of the members of the
Columbine duel wrote the human race
isn't worth fighting for only worth
killing give the earth back to the
animals they deserve it infinitely more
than we do nothing means anything
anymore
people who think such things view being
itself as inequitable and harsh to the
point of corruption and human being in
particular as contemptible they appoint
themselves supreme adjudicators of
reality and find it wanting
they're the ultimate critics the deeply
cynical writer continues if you recall
your history the Nazis came up with a
final solution to the Jewish problem
kill them all well in case you haven't
figured it out I say kill mankind
no one should survive for such
individuals the world of experience is
insufficient and evil so to hell with
everything what is happening when
someone comes to think in this manner a
great German play Faust a tragedy
written by Johann Wolfgang von Goethe
addresses that issue the play's main
character a scholar named Heinrich Faust
trades his immortal soul to the devil
mephistopheles in return he receives
whatever he desires while still alive on
earth in Bertha's play
mephistopheles is the eternal adversary
of being he has a central defining credo
I am the spirit who negates and rightly
so for all that comes to be deserves to
perish wretchedly it were better nothing
would begin thus everything that your
terms sin destruction evil represent
that is my proper element Goethe
considered this hateful sentiment so
important so key to the central element
of vengeful human destructiveness that
he had mefist awfully say it a second
time phrased somewhat differently in
part two of the play written many years
later people often think in the Memphis
to--they lien manner although they
seldom act upon their thoughts as
brutally as the mass murderers of school
college and theater whenever we
experience injustice real or imagined
and whenever we encounter tragedy or
fall prey to the machination z' of
others whenever we experience the horror
and pain of our own apparently arbitrary
limitations the temptation to question
being and then to curse it Rises Fowley
from the darkness
why must innocent people suffer so
terribly what kind of bloody horrible
planet is this anyway life is in truth
very hard everyone is destined for pain
and slated for destruction sometimes
suffering is clearly the result of
personal faults such as willful
blindness poor decision-making or
malevolence in such cases when it
appears to be self-inflicted it may even
seem just people get what they deserve
you might contend that's cold comfort
however even when true sometimes if
those who are suffering change their
behavior then their lives would unfold
less tragically but human control is
limited susceptibility to despair
disease ageing and death is universal in
the final analysis we do not appear to
be the architects of our own fragility
whose fault is it then
people who are very ill or worse who
have a sick child will inevitably find
themselves asking this question whether
they are religious believers or not the
same is true of someone who finds his
shirtsleeve caught in the gears of a
giant bureaucracy who is suffering
through a tax audit or fighting an
interminable lawsuit or divorce and it's
not only the obviously suffering who are
tormented by the need to blame someone
or something for the intolerable state
of their being at the height of his fame
influence and creative power
for example the towering Leo Tolstoy
himself began to question the value of
human existence
he reasoned in this way my position was
terrible I knew that I could find
nothing in the way of rational knowledge
except a denial of life and in faith I
could find nothing except a denial of
reason and this was even more impossible
than a denial of life according to
rational knowledge it followed that life
is evil and people know it they do not
have to live yet they have lived and
they do live just as I myself had lived
even though I had known for a long time
that life is meaningless and evil try as
he might Tolstoy could only identify for
means of escaping from such thoughts one
was retreating into childlike ignorance
of the problem
another was pursuing mindless pleasure
the third was continuing to drag out a
life that is evil and meaningless
knowing beforehand
that nothing can come of it he
identified that particular form of
escape with weakness the people in this
category know that death is better than
life but they do not have the strength
to act rationally and quickly put it
into the delusion by killing themselves
only the fourth and final mode of escape
involved strength and energy it consists
of destroying life once one has realized
that life is evil and meaningless
Tolstoy relentlessly followed his
thoughts only unusually strong and
logically consistent people act in this
manner
having realized all the stupidity of the
joke that is being played on us and
seeing that the blessings of the dead
are greater than those of the living and
that it is better not to exist they act
and put an end to this stupid joke and
they use any means of doing it a rope
around the neck water a knife in the
heart a train Tolstoy wasn't pessimistic
enough the stupidity of the
being played on us does not merely
motivate suicide it motivates murder
mass murder often followed by suicide
that is a far more effective existential
protest by June of 2016 unbelievable as
it may seem there had been 1,000 mass
killings defined as four or more people
shot in a single incident excluding the
shooter in the u.s. in twelve hundred
and sixty days
that's one such event on five of every
six days for more than three years
everyone says we don't understand
how can we still pretend that Tolstoy
understood more than a century ago the
ancient authors of the biblical story of
Cain and Abel understood as well more
than twenty centuries ago they described
murder as the first act of post identic
history and not just murder but
fratricidal murder murder not only of
someone innocent but of someone ideal
and good and murdered unconsciously to
spite the creator of the universe
today's killers tell us the same thing
in their own words who would dare say
that this is not the worm at the core of
the Apple but we will not listen because
the truth cuts too close to the bone
even for a mind as profound as that of
the celebrated Russian author there was
no way out how can the rest of us manage
when a man of Tolstoi stature admits
defeat for years he hid his guns from
himself and would not walk with a rope
in hand in case he hanged himself how
can a person who is awake avoid outrage
at the world
vengeance or transformation a religious
man might shake his fist in desperation
at the apparent injustice and blindness
of God even Christ himself felt
abandoned before the cross or so the
story goes more agnostic or atheistic
individual might blame fate or meditate
bitterly on the brutality of chance
another might tear himself apart
searching for the character flaws
underlying his suffering and
deterioration these are all variations
on a theme the name of the target
changes but the underlying psychology
remains constant why why is there so
much suffering and cruelty well perhaps
it really is God's doing or the fault of
blind pointless fate if you're inclined
to think that way and there appears to
be every reason to think that way but
what happens if you do mass murderers
believe that the suffering attendant
upon existence justifies judgment and
revenge as the Columbine boys so clearly
indicated I will sooner die than betray
my own thoughts before I leave this
worthless place I will kill whoever I
deem unfit for anything especially life
if you pissed me off in the past you
will die if I see you you might be able
to piss off others and have it
eventually all blow over but not me I
don't forget people who wronged me one
of the most vengeful murderers of the
20th century the terrible carl panzram
was raped brutalized and betrayed in the
minnesota institution responsible for
his rehabilitation when he was a
delinquent juvenile he emerged enraged
beyond measure as a burglar arsonist
rapists and serial killer
he aimed consciously and consistently at
destruction even keeping track of the
dollar value of the property he burned
he started by hating the individuals who
had hurt him his resentment grew until
his hatred encompassed all of mankind
and he didn't stop there
his destructiveness was aimed in some
fundamental manner at God himself
there's no other way of phrasing it
panzram raped murdered and burned to
express his outrage at being he acted as
if someone was responsible the same
thing happens in the story of Cain and
Abel Cain's sacrifices are rejected he
exists in suffering he calls out God and
challenges the being he created God
refuses his plea he tells Cain that his
trouble is self-induced Cain in his rage
kills Abel God's favorite and truth be
known Cain's idol Cain is jealous of
course of a successful brother but he
destroys Abel primarily to spite God
this is the truest version of what
happens when people take their vengeance
to the ultimate extreme pans Rams
response was and this is what is so
terrible perfectly understandable the
details of his autobiography revealed
that he was one of Tolstoy strong and
logically consistent people he was a
powerful consistent fearless actor he
had the courage of his convictions how
could someone like him be expected to
forgive and forget
given what had happened to him truly
terrible things happen to people it's no
wonder they're out for revenge
under such conditions vengeance seems a
moral necessity
how can it be distinguished from the
demand for justice after all after the
experience of terrible atrocity isn't
forgiveness just cowardice or lack of
willpower such questions torment me
but people emerge from terrible pasts to
do good and not evil although such an
accomplishment can seem superhuman I've
met people who managed to do it I know a
man a great artist who emerged from just
such a school as the one described by
panzram only this man was thrown into it
as an innocent five-year-old fresh from
a long stretch in the hospital where he
had suffered measles mumps and
chickenpox simultaneously incapable of
speaking the language of the school
deliberately isolated from his family
abused starved and otherwise tormented
he emerged an angry broken young man he
hurt himself badly in the aftermath with
drugs and alcohol and other forms of
self-destructive behavior he detested
everyone God himself
and blind fate included but he put it in
to all of that he stopped drinking
he stopped hating although it still
emerges in flashes he revitalized the
artistic culture of his native tradition
and trained young men to continue in his
footsteps he produced a 50 foot totem
pole memorializing the events of his
life and a canoe 40 feet long from a
single log of a kind rarely if ever
produced now he brought his family
together and held a great part Lodge
with 16 hours of dancing and hundreds of
people in attendance to express his
grief and make peace with the past he
decided to be a good person and then he
did the impossible things required to
live that way I had a client who did not
have good parents her mother died when
she was very young her grandmother who
raised her was a harridan bitter and /
concerned with appearances she
mistreated her granddaughter punishing
her for her virtues creativity
sensitivity intelligence unable to
resist acting out her
sentiment for an admittedly hard life on
her granddaughter she had a better
relationship with her father but he was
an addict who died badly while she cared
for him my client had a son she
perpetuated none of this with him he
grew up truthful and independent and
hardworking and smart instead of
widening the tear in the cultural fabric
she inherited and transmitting it she
sewed it up she rejected the sins of her
forefathers such things can be done
Nietzsche wrote these words distress
whether psychic physical or intellectual
need not at all produced nihilism that
is the radical rejection of value
meaning and desirability such distress
always permits a variety of
interpretations what Nietzsche meant was
this people who experience evil may
certainly desire to perpetuate it to pay
it forward but it is also possible to
learn good by experiencing evil a
bullied boy can mimic his tormentors but
it can also learn from his own abuse
that it is wrong to push people around
and make their lives miserable
someone tormented by her mother can
learn from her terrible experiences how
important it is to be a good parent many
perhaps even most of the adults who
abused children were abused themselves
as children however the majority of
people who were abused as children do
not abuse their own children this is a
well-established fact which can be
demonstrated simply arithmetic lee in
this way if one parent abused three
children and each of those children had
three children and so on then there
would be three abusers in the first
generation
in the second twenty seven the third
eighty-one the fourth and so on
exponentially after twenty generations
more than ten million would have
suffered childhood abuse more people
than currently inhabit the planet but
instead abuse disappears across
generations people constrain its spread
that's a testament to the genuine
dominance of good over evil in the human
heart the desire for vengeance however
justified also bars the way to other
productive thoughts the American English
poet TS Eliot explained why in his play
the cocktail party one of his characters
is not having a good time of it she
speaks of her profound unhappiness to a
psychiatrist she says she hopes all her
suffering is her own fault the
psychiatrist is taken aback he asks why
she has thought long and hard about this
she says and has come to the following
conclusion if it's her fault she might
be able to do something about it
if it's God's fault however if reality
itself is flawed hell-bent on ensuring
her misery and she is doomed
she couldn't change the structure of
reality itself but maybe she could
change her own life Alexander
Solzhenitsyn the great Russian
documenter of the abuses of Stalinism
had every reason to question the
structure of existence when he was
imprisoned in a Soviet labor camp in the
middle of the terrible 20th century he
had served as a soldier on the
ill-prepared Russian frontlines in the
face of a Nazi invasion he had been
arrested beaten and thrown into prison
by his own people then he was struck by
cancer he could have become resentful
and bitter his life had been
miserable by both Stalin and Hitler two
of the worst tyrants in history he lived
in brutal conditions vast stretches of
his precious time were stolen from him
and squandered he witnessed the
pointless and degrading suffering and
death of his friends and acquaintances
then he contracted an extremely serious
disease Solzhenitsyn had caused curse
God job himself barely had it as hard
but the great writer the profound
spirited defender of truth did not allow
his mind to turn towards vengeance and
destruction he opened his eyes instead
during his many trials Solzhenitsyn
encountered people who comported
themselves nobly under horrific
circumstances he contemplated their
behavior deeply then he asked himself
the most difficult of questions and he
personally contributed to the
catastrophe of his life if so how he
remembered his unquestioning support of
the communist party in his early years
he reconsidered his whole life he had
plenty of time in the camps how had he
missed the mark in the past how many
times had he acted against his own
conscience engaging in actions that he
knew to be wrong how many times had he
betrayed himself and lied was there any
way that the sins of his past could be
rectified atoned for in the muddy hell
of a Soviet gulag
Solzhenitsyn pored over the details of
his life with a fine-tooth comb he asked
himself a second question and a third
can I stop making such mistakes now can
I repair the damage done by my past
failures now he learned to watch and to
listen he found people he admired who
were honest despite everything he
himself apart piece-by-piece let what
was unnecessary and harmful died and
resurrected himself then he wrote the
Gulag Archipelago a history of the
soviet prison camp system it's a
forceful terrible book written with the
overwhelming moral force of unvarnished
truth
its sheer outrage screamed unbearably
across hundreds of pages banned and for
good reason in the USSR it was smuggled
to the west in the 1970s and burst upon
the world Solzhenitsyn's writing utterly
and finally demolished the intellectual
credibility of communism has ideologies
or society he took an axe to the trunk
of the tree whose bitter fruits had
nourished him so poorly and whose
planting he had witnessed and supported
one man's decision to change his life
instead of cursing fate shook the whole
pathological system of communist tyranny
to its core it crumbled entirely not so
many years later and Solzhenitsyn's
courage was not the least of the reasons
why he was not the only such person to
perform such a miracle václav havel the
persecuted writer who later impossibly
became the president of czechoslovakia
then of the new czech republic comes to
mind as does mahatma ghandi things fall
apart whole peoples have adamantly
refused to judge reality to criticize
being to blame god it's interesting to
consider the Old Testament Hebrews in
this regard their travails followed a
consistent pattern the stories of Adam
and Eve and Cain and Abel and Noah and
the Tower of Babel are truly ancient
their origins vanish into the mysteries
of time it's not until after the flood
story in Genesis that something like
history as we understand it true
starts it starts with Abraham Abraham's
descendants become the Hebrew people of
the Old Testament also known as the
Hebrew Bible they enter a covenant with
yahwah with god and began their
recognizably historical adventures under
the leadership of a great man the
hebrews organized themselves into a
society and then an empire as their
fortunes rise success breeds pride and
arrogance corruption raises its ugly
head the increasingly hubristic state
becomes obsessed with power begins to
forget its duty to the widows and the
orphans and deviates from its age-old
agreement with God a prophet arises he
brazenly and publicly reviles the
authoritarian king and faithless country
for their failures before God an act of
blind courage telling them of the
terrible judgment to come when his wise
words are not completely ignored they
are heeded too late God smites his
wayward people dooming them to abject
defeat in battle and generations of
subjugation the Hebrews repent at length
blaming their misfortune on their own
failure to adhere to God's Word they
insisted themselves that they could have
done better they rebuild their state and
the cycle begins again this is life we
build structures to live in we build
families and States and countries we
abstract the principles upon which those
structures are founded and formulate
systems of belief at first we inhabit
those structures and beliefs like Adam
and Eve in Paradise but success makes us
complacent we forget to pay attention we
take what we have for granted we turn a
blind eye we fail to notice that things
are changing or that corruption is
taking root and everything falls apart
is that the fault of reality or God or
do things fall apart because
we have not paid sufficient attention
when the hurricane hit New Orleans and
the towns sank under the waves was that
a natural disaster the Dutch prepare
their dikes for the worst storm in
10,000 years had New Orleans followed
that example no tragedy would have
occurred it's not that no one knew the
Flood Control Act of 1965 mandated
improvements in the levee system that
held back Lake Pontchartrain
the system was to be completed by 1978
40 years later only 60 percent of the
work had been done willful blindness and
corruption took the city down a
hurricane is an act of God but failure
to prepare when the necessity for
preparation is well-known that's sin
that's failure to hit the mark and the
wages of sin is death Romans 6:23 the
ancient Jews always blamed themselves
when things fell apart they acted as if
God's goodness the goodness of reality
was axiomatic and took responsibility
for their own failure that's insanely
responsible but the alternative is to
judge reality as insufficient to
criticize being itself and to sink into
resentment and the desire for revenge if
you are suffering well that's the norm
people are limited and life is tragic
if your suffering is unbearable however
and you are starting to become corrupted
here's something to think about clean up
your life consider your circumstances
start small have you taken full
advantage of the opportunities offered
to you are you working hard on your
career or even your job or are you
letting bitterness and resentment hold
you back and drag you down
have you made peace with your brother
are you treating your spouse and your
children with dignity and respect
do you have habits that are destroying
your health and well-being are you truly
shouldering your responsibilities have
you said what you need to say to your
friends and family members are there
things that you could do that you know
you could do that would make things
around you better have you cleaned up
your life if the answer is no here's
something to try start to stop doing
what you know to be wrong start stopping
today
don't waste time questioning how you
know that what you're doing is wrong if
you're certain that it is inopportune
questioning can confuse without
enlightening as well as deflecting you
from action you can know that something
is wrong or right without knowing why
your entire being can tell you something
that you can neither explain nor
articulate every person is too complex
to know themselves completely and we all
contain wisdom that we cannot comprehend
so simply stop when you apprehend
however dimly that you should stop stop
acting in that particular despicable
manner stop saying those things that
make you weak and ashamed say only those
things that make you strong do only
those things that you could speak of
with honor you can use your own
standards of judgment you can rely on
yourself for guidance you don't have to
adhere to some external arbitrary code
of behavior although you should not
overlook the guidance of your culture
life is short and you don't have time to
figure out everything on your own the
wisdom of the past was hard-earned and
your dead ancestors may have something
useful to tell you don't blame
capitalism the radical left or the
iniquity
of your enemies don't reorganize the
state until you have ordered your own
experience have some humility if you
cannot bring peace to your household how
dare you try to rule a city let your own
soul guide you watch what happens over
the days and weeks when you were at work
you will begin to say what you really
think you will start to tell your wife
or your husband or your children or your
parents what you really want and need
when you know that you have left
something undone you will act to correct
the omission your head will start to
clear up as you stop filling it with
lies your experience will improve as you
stop distorting it with inauthentic
actions you will then begin to discover
new more subtle things that you are
doing wrong stop doing those - after
some months and years of diligent effort
your life will become simpler and less
complicated your judgment will improve
you will untangle your past you will
become stronger and less bitter you will
move more confidently into the future
you will stop making your life
unnecessarily difficult you will then be
left with the inevitable bear tragedies
of life but they will no longer be
compounded with bitterness and deceit
perhaps you will discover that you're
now less corrupted soul much stronger
than it might otherwise have been is now
able to bear those remaining necessary
minimal inescapable tragedies perhaps
you will even learn to encounter them so
that they stay tragic merely tragic
instead of degenerating into outright
hellishness maybe your anxiety and
hopelessness and resentment and anger
however murderous initially will recede
perhaps your
corrupted soul will then see its
existence as a genuine good as something
to celebrate even in the face of your
own vulnerability perhaps you will
become an ever more powerful force for
peace and whatever is good perhaps you
will then see that if all people did
this in their own lives the world might
stop being an evil place after that with
continued effort perhaps it could even
stop being a tragic place
who knows what existence might be like
if we all decided to strive for the best
who knows what eternal heavens might be
established by our spirits purified by
truth aiming skyward right here on the
Fallen earth set your house in perfect
order before you criticize the world